How do you detach without
seeming completely cold?
Okay, important question. Yeah.
I say this all time. You know,
you got to detach.
I also say all the time,
if you detach from all of your emotions,
that means your robot and people don't
fall robots. I say it all the time.
So when you do detach,
you can't,
you can't completely step away.
But if you do,
you have to.
You have to act. You have
to do a little acting. Now,
first of all, we already
talked about this, right?
We already talked about these red flags
that that show that you're going to lose
your temper, that you're going
to get emotional about something.
You know your clenched fist and your
raised voice and you're heavy breathing in
your flared nostrils and all that stuff,
right?
So you know what those things mean.
Those things mean those things are your,
your signal. That mean detach. Okay,
so you got to work on that. Yeah.
Now,
here's the dichotomy of it is once you
are there and once you have detached,
you actually have to now go back and do
one or some of those things that you are
trying not to do. You have to go
and get the doom a little bit. Hmm.
In a nice little controlled manner,
right?
Maybe you raise your voice a little bit,
maybe you just kind of clench your jaw
and you remember I said to you like,
like nodding your head in a positive
way. And that's a, that's a s when you,
if you're coming to me with an issue
and I nod my head to the affirmative,
you know, up and down saying,
yes, I understand. Yes,
I understand that's a soothing thing to
your team, right? They see that you're,
you're okay with it.
The opposite of that is when you
shake your head too in the negative.
Like if you're telling me some problem
and I'm shaking my head, it's like,
now I'm me going, Tim, I can't
believe this is going on. Right? So,
so maybe that's another thing that
you, you, you Clint, your drawing,
you shake your head to just
show the person like, look,
I know we're in a bad way.
I get it. I'm not sitting back
here like it's no big deal.
I know it's going to be a tough, I know
we just lost a sale or I know we just,
you know, I'm going to have to plan
another mission that we just got back.
I understand that it's hard.
You care. I care. You know I'm,
I'm with you.
You want to give that maybe you let
out that little sigh of frustration,
you know, like a little like
something like that, right?
Just going to do that little thing.
Just do that.
Just self showing that you do got some
emotions and you are invested in all that
stuff. And, and then once,
once you see that you've
achieved your goal here,
that you can see that,
that they see that you have some
emotions on the situation, then you,
you quickly get yourself
to recover from that.
You get yourself composed and you've
shown them and they, and they've seen,
it's almost like a little see, like
a little weakness and they go, okay,
you don't Trocco's are human related.
Yeah, I can relate, but he's mad.
But you know, I actually want him to calm
down. I actually am glad he's so good.
Yardi I'm using to be like, I'm glad
he's calming down. That's good. Okay,
so the new recover, you go back to
your calm, cool, collected self.
Right. That's what we're going to
do now. Like I said, this is the,
we call this acting.
I guess maybe we could call it acting,
but at the same time acting means you're
trying to pretend to be somebody, right.
You're not trying to pretend to
be anybody else. You're being you.
That's all you're doing. You're being
you. You're just acting like yourself.
Just showing a little bit
more of the emotion. And
then you would be,
if you were just completely detached.
So it's not like you're trying
to act like some, you know,
all this junior. Yeah. You're not
trying to play a role of someone else.
You're just being you so,
and you already know what you do because
you've learned how what the signals are.
So when you know that you raise your
voice and that means you're okay.
You just raise your voice a little bit.
If you know that you,
you just give a little sides
as those careful things.
And so yeah,
I guess it is acting in a way,
but it's not full on anybody
can do it, I think. Yeah.
Yeah, you did. I think that's
great. This is my opinion.
You do it with your kids, you
know? I mean, I'm like, yeah,
you got to pretend to act. Yeah. You know
you're mad or, or whatever. Any good.
Even happy, even pretend to act happy. Oh
No, it's okay. We'll say excited.
Look, hey, I got something for you.
It's a drawing of the happy face.
Same as she did yesterday. You know?
It's like I'm not, the honest truth
is I'm excited about other things.
We'll just say that
I haven't done all those. I not love
all that love you got for crying about
that letter. You're going
to, you're going to know.
And it's all going backwards now.
People are going to hate you now
talking about your daughter Jaws,
you a beautiful picture and you don't
care about it. It's cold blooded.
What am I going to give
her is a lot of excitement.
I'm going to metric excitement,
maybe even go one level higher.
That's what I'm going to give her.
So I'm, what am I asking? Acting.
I'm excited about a lot of
things. A little bit though.
It's the same. Same thing.
Same thing. Yeah. Uh, that was messed
up by the way. Same thing. Yeah,
I know. I know. Is it
a form of manipulation?
It might be a little bit of
form of emulation, but again,
if you're doing it to help the individual
and you're doing it to help the team,
then isn't manipulation or
is it leadership? I say,
of course it's leadership.
You're not manip manipulation is,
I'm trying to fool you so you do things
that I want you to do that are to hurt
you. We're not doing that. That's
not what we're running here. Shit.